it's your natural yeah you're a
tarantula
detective into the tutor science or
source to the Patrick no ok so it's like
and then it's like Oh God got me on this
she does that to me when she's like you
know I'm sending you something yes
pterodactyl
Josh wouldn't know to know um yeah we're
a generation
detective into the tutor science and
source to the trapper know very small
and I having a Napoleon complex
and I'm on a TV show oh oh and and cool
clip ran cool clip and pizzas pizzas my
father
Oh
so I'm not gonna move my hair but
pretend I have really high ponytail yeah
a really really high ponytail and she
whenever she does like musical
impression she's like this I was like
what are you who would have a hot oh
okay yes you're really good at whatever
you're doing yeah wait I pretty much
only where you should have been laying
husband's I was only exclusively where
you Z oh that's cool I would have had
good to know let me finish my scene
sorry I'm just too good yah yah yah yah
yah yah
walk the pasture don't you walk the
future that's really good that's what
I'm winging it right oh good um your
hearts your nails how that was more of
an old man
breakdown I played high five I'm gonna
meant as like
what up everybody I'm Noah centenary and
I'm Lana Condor and this was first
impressions with Thailand that was fun
knowing your Yoda is good